so um this will be a very different talk
than the last one we heard so like a lot
of philosophers I'm interested in very
general questions and this is a question
that I pursued in very different ways uh
what are the nature scope and limits of
knowledge in physics and other
philosophers of science have looked at
other fields of course I've just by
chance ended up and by interest working
primarily on physics and really I've
been looking a lot at trying to
understand what's going on in physics in
order to answer these sorts of
epistemological questions I've often
pursued historical case studies looking
at the detailed development mhone sorry
looking at the detailed development of
particular Fields as a way to try to
address this question but today I want
to talk about a different question
focusing on a type of Sciences or a kind
of approach to Scientific projects that
I'll Loosely call historical sciences
and so this actually I should credit a a
former PhD student of mine Craig Fox who
who worked on this for a thesis a few
years ago so it's really working with
him that got me interested in these
questions and also of course it's
relevant to cosmology which is something
I've thought a lot about um and it turns
out that there's a small group of people
within philosophy of science who've been
looking at this question as well so um I
think a shared theme of discussions of
historical Sciences is that and this is
not surprising that a lot of the
reasoning in historical Sciences is
reconstructing history based on traces
that we have in the present and the
question is how much can we do with that
so I think there was for a while a sort
of crude assumption that the historical
Sciences were worse off compared to
experimental Sciences um and that you'd
face a kind of underdetermination threat
in historical Sciences um there are
different ways of expressing this worry
one is just that you would have a sort
of Decay or loss of information over
time so that the traces of pass events
will be harder to access later and also
just the obvious fact that we don't have
uh the ability to manipulate historical
systems and the way that we often are
able to manipulate um experimental
systems so there's a variety of people
who've uh have classified as pessimist
sober is more complicated he's
optimistic about some things and has
some more pessimistic arguments as well
um Derek Turner had The Misfortune of
doing what philosophers often do which
is announce that certain things will be
impossible um so he uh as a side note in
a paper said well there are some things
we'll never know about the past such as
the color of dinosaurs um like a lot of
philosophical pronouncements of that
sort that was like a Prelude to conquest
by science so a few years later
paleontologist gathered evidence that
seems to give them Good Grounds for
establishing what the color of dinosaurs
are um so I think these are real
concerns and I think one of the overall
questions I often ask and trying to
address the big question is what are the
evidential challenges that a field faces
and how have scientists overcome those
challenges and to what extent have they
done so the more recent literature on
historical sciences and here Adrian
Curry's book as a good example you can
see just in the subtitle of the book
it's an optimist Guide to the historical
sciences and so he's really defending
the claim that historical Sciences have
been able to establish results with as
much certainty as we have in other areas
of science um and some of this work has
focused on case studies of specific
examples of historical sciences that
seem to have delivered um uh really firm
results and knowledge of the past um
there's one kind of argument that so
Carol Cleland in particular in a 2001
paper argued that we can address the
pessimist uh worry by appealing to an
asymmetry of overdetermination that the
effects overdetermine causes and so
there's a way of thinking about this
that she's borrowing from the
philosopher David Lewis and his analysis
of the asymmetry of causation and I
think although I'm much more on The
Optimist side I find that way of framing
the discussion to be a bit limiting and
partly there's things that I'll leave
off stage just uh it's partly criticisms
of Lewis's analysis of counterfactual
asymmetry but what I'd like to do today
is to to suggest a different way of
framing the discussion that's based on
some of the causation and especially the
interventionist approach to causation
that I've been dipping into recently so
this was an invitation that came at a
good time because I've just started
looking at this and so it's great to to
have uh benefited from The Talk
yesterday and you'll see that there's a
lot of common themes so the way I think
that it's uh possible to pose the
question slightly differently is is to
say what does the world have to be like
to enable reliable reconstructions of
the deep past in so far as we have been
able to succeed in giving those and I'm
going to focus just on two aspects of
this question here so this is there's a
a phrase I think is originally Jim
Woodwards but it's in the title of a
paper by NA T and Jim and Porter
Williams a really recent paper that says
the question is what's the worldly
infrastructure so what has to be present
in the world to underwrite our ability
to make causal inferences and so I think
there's some very similar features that
are important for understanding causal
inferences in the Deep past and so I
should say also I think it's important
that these are causal inferences because
I think the scientists who are
investigating the Deep past are not just
interested in establishing what happened
they're also interested in establishing
causal accounts of what happened so I
think it is crucial that it's a causal
inference and not just a a
reconstruction effort and the other
point I'll make um so uh I think the
methodology of uh Trace based reasoning
and reconstructions based on traces is
certainly substantially correct but I
think there's actually a stronger notion
there are some cases which I'll call
time capsules and it might be more a
difference of degree than of kind but
there are some kinds of systems that
allow us to make astonishingly good
inferences about pass States and so I'm
going to argue that the feature of the
world that allows for those kinds of
time capsules is a kind of decoupling
that's been mentioned in a few earlier
talks already so those are the two
things I'm going to focus on as the
features that I think the world has to
have in order to underwrite
reconstructions of the deep past so let
me start by just I'll first talk about
this the relevant notion of Independence
before going back to decoupling and
Tracy traces and then I'll very briefly
comment on early Universe cosmology
so um I'm going to use an example here
briefly to illustrate the importance of
a notion of independence of the initial
conditions so this goes back to the 19th
century when lud boltzman uh derived
what he called the H theorem so the
image across the top is meant to be
something like an ideal gas interacting
where the it's just pairwise
interactions between the gas uh
molecules bouncing off of each other
this is meant to be a Time series where
you can see the and if you look at the
red you can see that the the the well
the red dots move in such a way that you
could imagine that they've interacted
with the nearby particles and have
bounced off of them now the Striking
thing that uh boltzman derived is that
he argued that there's an evolution
towards an equilibrium State namely a
particular distribution of velocities in
the gas called the maxwellian velocity
distribution but as various people soon
pointed out that was incredibly puzzling
because the Dynamics describing these
collisions the pairwise collisions
between the molecules were completely
time reversal and variant so how could
you get a monotonic Evolution towards
equilibrium when you have time reversal
and variant Dynamics and the the source
of the asymmetry was an assumption that
might have seemed innocent which uh he
called the stanz which we usually call
molecular chaos which is that the
interacting particles before they
Collide their their states their
velocities and positions are independent
of one another they're not correlated um
but of course that's a Time asymmetric
assumption if you have the two particles
Collide afterwards their velocities and
positions will be correlated with one
another and so by initially setting
those correlations aside you're
introducing a subtle sort of time
asymmetric initial
condition so um and you can think about
what how you could set up an anti-
thermodynamic Evolution namely an ideal
gas that doesn't go towards equilibrium
doesn't go towards the maxwellian
velocity distribution so this is the way
to to set it up consider any system that
evolves towards equilibrium now imagine
that you can reverse all of the
velocities of the particles and the
micro state that you've defined in this
way under the Dynamics there's an
allowed Evolution that goes exactly the
opposite of the evolution that just got
you into the state and so that final
micro state will then evolve away from
equilibrium but there's some really
surprising things about this right the
first is that what you're doing is
taking all the correlations that exist
in that final State and you're using the
Dynamics to sort of unwind those to take
you back towards the initial State and
so it's an anti- thermodynamic evolution
in the sense that this is not the kind
of thing we see everyday gas is doing
it's against all of the features we see
uh uh the the evolution towards
equilibrium but the thing I want to
focus on is just that there are really
two features of this anti- thermodynamic
Evolution that we can think of in terms
of the independence of the state so
first of all when I've defined this
state this way I've defined a state that
has a huge number of complicated
correlations between the states of the
particles right that's how I've
introduced it and that's essential to
have those correlations present in order
to be able to uh determine that
dynamical
trajectory um there's a second point
which is a little more subtle is it's
also the case that the reverse state is
dependent on the Dynamics that I've used
to describe the evolution of the gas if
I had a slightly different dynamics that
abnormal State even though it's got all
the correlations wouldn't evolve anti-
thermodynamically right so it's both the
the state has in the uh the the
specification of the particles they're
all very delicately dependent on each
other and exactly what state it is that
leads to the anti- thermodynamic
Evolution depends on the knowledge of
the Dynamics of that system as
well I should say I I have very ref uh
various references here very little of
what I'm saying now is original at all
it's just setting up um a point or maybe
nothing I'm saying at this point is
original um now I think there's a number
of similar kinds of assumptions about
independence that arise in physics so
the first point is we can just
generalize what boltzman was talking
about and it arises in other cases where
um physicists in statistical mechanics
derive time asymmetric macroscopic
Dynamics using core graining and so on
I'm not going to go into the details of
that but a lot of these uh technical uh
practices involve something much like uh
what we saw in Bolton H theorem namely
throwing away correlations between
subsystems in order to to uh derive an
asymmetric
Evolution um you can see this in an
assumption of no source-free radiation
so this is often Illustrated using the
example of a stone thrown into a pond
when we throw a stone in a pond we see
the waves Ripple out we very rarely see
waves converge and cause a stone to be
thrown out of the pond that kind of
evolution would require the same sort of
coherent Evolution from this state in
order to have the kind of time reversal
of what we usually uh would expect to
see and so the there's another condition
that you can impose that will rule out
exactly that kind of case and finally I
mean we could go on there's a lot of
different cases that uh illustrate this
point here's a more subtle one it's
actually quite there's a recent paper by
Williams Miller and dhy that analyzes
something that Weinberg introduced as an
axiom of qft the cluster decomposition
Principle as he called it so imagine you
have clusters of fields interacting with
one another and then you take those to
be further and further away
and the claim is that the vacuum
expectation values are the S Matrix
elements that you would use to calculate
things in particle accelerators but
those become independent As you move
those far away so again it's a way of
saying that the the probability
distribution factorizes is a pre precise
way of making this Independence claim
and again I think this is the kind of
thing that you will find in a lot of
different aspects of physics
Independence assumptions of this sort so
I think we can see the um inter
interventionist approach to causation as
Woodward form formulates it as
highlighting two very similar features
to what I've just introduced in terms of
the physics so these are more General
statements of the same kind of
Independence that I've seen that I've
been highlighting as well motivated
physically so this is the first is very
close to the causal Markoff condition
that we saw in Thomas's talk yesterday I
think this is actually slightly weaker
logically but you know if we have a
bunch of random variables if none are
causes of other variables and none a
common cause then they should be
statistically independent so that's like
the first claim I was saying and the
second but I don't really like the the
name but I guess it's it's good enough
value relationship Independence this is
related to the idea that the way that
the initial variables are specified
should be independent of the law or the
causal generalization that's relevant to
them so these are exactly the two
features we saw earlier in the case of
the boltson H theorem so
um so so I think the let me just pause
for a moment and emphasize here so the
the point is I think these aspects of
the intervist program are actually good
ways of characterizing Independence
postulat that play an essential role in
physics as well and so I see these as
sort of a generalization from plausible
physical principles that seem to play an
important role uh in a variety of
aspects of physics now I think a natural
response that you might have had when I
said I was going to use an
interventionist approach to causation
and thinking about the history of the
deep past is to say interventions why
are you talking about interventions
right so um so and this is just again we
saw this yesterday in several talks uh a
definition of cause from an
interventionist program um requires that
you know that it's in effect you're able
to pick out and directly intervene on a
cause that then has the uh intended
effect um and so the question here would
be is it possible to control a variable
Y and only that variable by acting on
its cause right so can you locate an
inter a sort of surgical intervention in
that kind of way now the reason why this
might seem implausible is something we
try to apply to the Deep past is what
what could we mean by possible here
right so if you're doing an experimental
science you could try to do these
directly um to assess the possibility
because you could determine whether your
causal graph is appropriately modeling
the data you're looking at um by trying
the interventions and seeing seeing what
happens so the but there's a basic
question here about how do we assess
possibility and I think actually so this
goes back to Woodward's uh book from
several years ago now I don't think we
need to think possible as just
experimental manipulation there's a much
Broad broader notion of possibility here
and so uh as Woodward says he doesn't
even think it has to be physically
possible he has a little bit further
discussion here about a strong sense of
physical possibility and so on but
really the question is can you define an
intervention can you actually specify an
interv intervention that would have the
features uh that we noted uh before and
I think in a lot of cases we can
actually think of defining interventions
in a much looser way namely that we can
think of uh obviously an experimental
context but we can think of natural
experiments where we think of the
environment as having an impact on the
system where it will influence a
particular variable um and so natural
experiments allow you to see that you
can have if if nature cooperates you can
see the variation in that variable as a
result of the way the system interacts
with the environment so you have an
effect uh implemented that manipulation
by looking at these separate systems and
I think we also can assess these
questions of possibility in some cases
by doing simulations where we can
explore the possibility space and see
what's possible in terms of varying um
different uh variables so it's not
really um something that is tied to
human capabilities in this definition of
causation but I do think it's really
important to ask so all of these
assessments do involve some kind of
modal commitments so what's the way that
the system interacts with the
environment how do we think about Poss
ibility how's that enshrined in our
simulations so I think we do want to say
that we can only use this if our modal
assessments are at least uh have clear
truth conditions so that we can
determine uh whether a particular
intervention is possible now let me say
um if we think of our anti-
thermodynamic Evolution and we imagine
the gas now evolving away from
equilibrium and let's say we tried to
intervene on that system in some way
right so that we would modify its course
of
evolution um here I think when we start
to think about this we can see how hard
it is to imagine what an intervention
would look like in that case um that's
because we would any anything we might
try to do would disrupt the carefully
coordinated Evolution that's leading it
away from equilibrium and so it seems
like any intervention is going to rather
than changing let's say we want to
change something about the final state
any intervention is going to change
everything about the system right and so
this is a point made that by Adam Elga
and then Porter Williams has another
recent discussion of this so it's hard
to see how you could intervene in a
system that had that kind of uh uh
Evolution so that's a case where I'd say
if you're trying to intervene in a world
that had a failure of Independence then
it seems I have no understanding of what
interventions would mean in that context
but I think in other contexts
we can say that we have an understanding
of the modal assessment necessary to to
to make these sorts of Assessments so I
think we can for example going to the
second Point here we can give a modal
assessment of system environment
interactions sources of exogenous
variation I think that's what people in
historical Sciences are often doing and
have clear grounds for doing um as we'll
come back to right at the end I think it
does get more tricky if we're talking
about global properties of systems or uh
Global States or closed
systems and so the other thing as I just
emphasized before I think the uh uh
interventionist Assumption of uh
Independence um the the feature that I
think is really interesting is it
depends not just on the laws but it also
depends on features of the initial state
that the initial state is uncorrelated
in an appropriate
sense so that's a brief summary of why I
think the um interventionist approach
brings brings out some features of
causal inference that we can helpfully
apply to historical sciences and I want
to now shift to really briefly discuss
decoupling and traces so um inferring
causes from traces this is the standard
kind of picture that you know uh Thomas
mentioned before as well that we see all
kinds of cases where we say there's an
event such as a baseball going through
the window you have a lot of evidence
the glass yards on the floor the base
your child's sheepish look or if it was
one of my daughters You' just see them
running out of the door to avoid what
was coming next but the the traces then
overdetermine the cause that's the sort
of line that uh Carol Cleland gives and
I think there's something that's right
about it but I think there's something
that is missing in these accounts which
I think is actually really essential for
the at least the historical sciences
that I've looked at which is that I
think there are cases that are quite a
bit more powerful than just inference
from traces so so Dave gave gave us a
beautiful discussion of the CMB
yesterday so I deleted a bunch of slides
and the the really crucial point that I
want to emphasize is that after about
380,000 years after the big bang the
photons
decouple and they free stream
essentially to our satellites that are
observing them or our TVs if you have an
old TV and through that Evolution the uh
the the photons themselves the average
properties for the whole Sky there's
really no dynamical process that is
feasible that would modify the average
temperature of the CMB other than the
fact that due to cosmological expansion
the temperature is Chang changing with
the scale factor so if you ask what is
the uh mapping from the current
observations of the CMB back to the
early Universe it's really a direct
mapping so the only there are local
variations which are quite important but
you have a really direct mapping back to
the early state of the universe and so I
think this seems to me stronger than a
trace and it's actually uh one thing
that Dave also emphasized but I think is
worth saying more uh saying once more
the CMB has driven cosmology for the
last 50 years so it's enabled Precision
cosmology in a way that other
observations are now catching up to but
the the the level of precision that's
available in observations of the CMB and
the fact that we've kept coming back for
more there's more and more features of
the CMB that have been revealing further
details about the early universe that
are very rich and important in
constraining and understanding
cosmological theories so I think it's a
bit stronger than just a trace and so
this is uh a group in 1957 at MIT who
are confident that this time capsule
that they're installing I don't know
where it is on campus um would be dug up
in 2957 so they expect it to last for a
millennia so that's a that's a good
optimistic take um and I think that a
lot of systems that people use in
historical Sciences are time capsules in
roughly the sense of this sort of
everyday Time Capsule namely it's a
quasi isolated system that evolves
according to its own Dynamics in some
sense like the CMB there's an autonomous
dynamics that governs the temperature um
and it has it's quasi isolated in the
sense that there are very few dynamical
interactions that will disturb the state
of the Time Capsule um obviously this is
defas like it's something that you can
have failures of that that sort of
isolation but there are a lot of cases
where the time capsules also give you
further information such as an internal
clock that allows you to not just say uh
infer what the state of a system was
earlier but infer something about the
time elapsed since it decoupled from the
environment and so this is actually a
really rich source of information and I
have one example that it's something
that uh you might not have heard of
before um so isotopic ratios are a good
time capsule because there's very few
things that change the isotopic ratios
for radioactive elements and so this is
a a mine in Gabon that uh in the early
70s people discovered something quite
unusual and this was the Cold War era
the uh amount of uranium 235 compared to
uranium 238 was wrong and so they
thought maybe there was some you know
maybe the Soviets had doing something
maybe there's some kind of nuclear uh uh
activity taking place and it turns out
there was nuclear activity but it was
actually naturally occurring nuclear
reactors so they uh because of the low
230 uh AME 235 abundances they did some
reconstructions and so this is a map
that shows in the black spots are where
uh naturally occurring fision reactors
uh took place about 1.7 billion years
ago and so what this illustrates is is
that there's a time capsule the the the
isotopic ratios are so secure that
you're able to discover like what could
possibly have changed those isotopic
ratios it's essentially only a vision
reaction and then they're able to
reconstruct How could a fision reaction
have taken place it has to do with the
groundwater um 1.7 billion years ago
there was more
u235 uh present and then they could
confirm that by looking at other kind of
Decay products of the interaction and
they could see also from the shape of
The Rock that had been heated up quite
significantly so that's just an example
of how uh the departure from this quasi
isolate Dynamics is also incredibly
revealing um now I've used examples from
physics just because that's what I know
but I would expect that there are
similar kinds of systems in biology and
evolutionary biology where you can think
of them as something more like a time
capsule that gives you a very secure way
of inferring earlier states of the
system of
Interest okay okay so what does the
world have to be like to enable
reconstructions of the deep past well I
focus first on worldly infrastructure
now in terms of traces and time capsules
really this is very similar to a theme
that has come up in a few of the talks
before that what is uh important here is
a kind of dynamical decoupling of
systems from their environment so that
they uh evolve independently and they
can be treated as isolated systems and
that's something we've seen in other
contexts in physics where people have
been using effective field theories very
well where you have a kind of scale
separation that allows you to treat
these as uh separable now obviously this
is going to be I don't know that I can
say much more generally about this it's
going to be very background Theory
dependent being able to find a time
capsule figuring out how to use it but I
think our world does provide us with
some of these time capsules and very
persistent and revealing
traces okay so the um very last uh brief
comment on early Universe cosmology so I
mentioned before I think that there are
some issues regarding cosmology but I
first want to say I think this is a very
limited part of cosmology that poses
particular problems so I think in a lot
of cases in
cosmology we actually can try to make
the modal assessment of whether
something is a possible in intervention
by the same ways that we do in other
context so either through natural
experiment looking at a large sample of
similar systems and seeing how some
features vary across the different uh
elements of that Ensemble or exploring
possibility spaces through simulations
where we have a lot large confidence in
the theories that we're using to
construct those simulations so I think
for a lot of questions in cosmology we
can answer these interventionist
questions perfectly well I think in some
cases though and in particular in the
early Universe this is more of an N
equals one problem as Dave emphasized
last time because we don't have any
other realizations and then we Face the
the difficulty of drawing a contrast
between lawlike and contingent features
and furthermore the theory that's
developed to render an observed history
plausible to make it the case that what
we see is to be expected giving our
understanding of the Dynamics is also
really only tested through those same
observations and the the ability to
reconstruct history so there's a kind of
worry about a circularity there that I
think is is really hard to to get around
so I think in that case it's not clear
that the interventionist approach helps
in in addressing that problem just
because we Face the problem of not
really understanding modalities uh as as
clearly as we do in other
context okay so um just to summarize
then what does the world have to be like
to enable reliable reconstructions so
I've argued that the kinds of
assumptions that are needed to be in
place for a causal uh interventionist
causal analysis also have to be in place
here that we need an independence
assumptions and then also to understand
the modal status of interventions and
also that I think there's more
interesting kinds of traces which I've
called time capsules that really do
provide a lot of information and what
seems to be the general feature that
allows for those to exist is a
decoupling of systems that uh makes it
possible for those to be treated as
effectively isolated so thank you very
much
for keeping the time uh
questions
Eduardo thank you Chris very very
interesting
talk I I just want to have hear your
thoughts you were telling us how you
feel comfortable moving some data in
cosmology from maybe traces to something
that you would call evidence or
observation and I wonder why do we need
are we I mean I was just pulling up an
essay that most of you probably know
because it's by Carl San on the burden
of skepticism that I give to the
students all the time right why do we
need to do that unless what we're trying
to do is to move from just taking the
results face value to making decisions
that are contingent on whether we're
going to consider it a trace or a
confirmed fact and he was thinking it
was making me think about how I would
like science or Society to operate with
the same kind of data if you're this ing
father uncertainty in Al monkeys or you
have a human being in a court of law who
may go to jail for my assessments of
paternity it could be the same numbers
the same data but we may still decide to
call one not enough to make on to moving
the decision and the other one I can
live with making I mean I allow myself
to call this a fact if I'm discussing
all monkeys in a workshop at Yale but I
may I want to keep keep calling it a
trace because I do not want to pass
judgment on somebody who may or may not
be the father of this young so I think
again it it takes us going back and
forth between the actual
results and our assumption that we're
going to use that for something else
right no I think this is a general
feature that epistemic standards that
are appropriate to different context
shift right so I think um and I think
cosmology there aren't as many decision
contexts where it really matters if the
if you've got the right value of the
Hubble constant right so um I think
there's um there's different ways of uh
asking the decision question though
which I think um if you're going to take
something as giving you insight into the
causal structure of how the universe
evolved um I think that gives you a much
richer sense of the further consequences
of that and so some of this is a
slightly different question you're
asking more like like how should we
classify something as a trace or how
confident should we be in thinking of it
as a time capsule um there's also then
if you use it in a certain way you might
get a better picture of like here's the
causal structure and then that might
have further implications for other
aspects of cosmological modeling right
so I think in cosmology just because
it's a intrinsically incredibly valuable
field but not something that has like
direct extrinsic impact on day-to-day
decisions for the most part I think
that's going to be the impact is more on
the implications for other aspects of
cosmological modeling um and then yeah I
think your degree of confidence can
shift like if it's something that you
think is um an essential feature of your
modeling and you're going to build like
20 years worth of research on this you'd
probably have a want or you know I think
a different way this comes up is like
motivating large scale very expensive
telescopes you want to have a lot of
confidence that what you're looking for
is really something that's a uh going to
be very de decisive in answering the
question you're interested in and so you
might then have a very careful analysis
of like how certain are we about this as
as a s so when we want to make decisions
about public money investment right for
example yeah
Alex uh thanks um I wanted to just um
ask a bit more about the focus on the
Deep past as opposed to recent past
because it seemed like um you know this
question of kind of what's the scope and
limits of our knowledge about the Deep
path you could also ask about the recent
past and you were saying that for
current or recent things we can like
perform experiments in a way that we
can't directly perform experiments about
the Deep past but on the other hand it
is still true that in in order to be
able to trust our memories of the recent
past we were relying on assumptions
about there aren't a lot of anti-
thermodynamic things happening so I was
wondering like the conditions you listed
would you also think them to be
basically necessary for knowledge of the
recent past and if so so then how do you
see the focus on the Deep past as you
know what's the importance of that Focus
as opposed to just focus on the past in
general yeah no so there's a lot of the
story that I think would be roughly the
same for the recent past so you have to
have an account of memory you have to
have an account of how it is that you
form records or take certain things as
records and I think that doesn't really
discriminate between the Deep past and
recent past so a lot of what I say I
think just does carry over but I think
the partly it's within the context of U
the recent discussions of the historical
sciences that people are stating these
uh kinds of pessimism that do depend on
the the amount of time lapse so even so
I think for some of the some of the
Skeptics even if you imagine that you
know if my daughter broke the window
yesterday I could find the traces if
that's the way you think of the evidence
is working and you think that those
traces Decay over time then you have a
reason for thinking that the account of
the recent past just won't extend that
far and part of what I'm arguing is
actually if you uh if you have something
like a time capsule that actually can be
stable over you know 13.8 billion years
right so so I think the some of what I'm
saying is that there are some systems
that allow you to extend much more
straightforwardly into the deep past and
I think that just hasn't been fully
recognized in in the the reliability of
the evidence right basically can be can
be quite different so in the interest of
not keeping everyone um uh away from
lunch too long let's thank Chris and
move on to
our final pre lunch
talk